if I were to draw a hand let me just
draw a hand really fast so I'll draw a
left hand looks something like that
that is a left hand now if I were to
take its mirror image so let's say that
this is a mirror right there and I want
to take its mirror image and I'll draw
the mirror image in green so it's mirror
image would look something like this it
looks something like this not exact but
you get the idea the mirror image of a
left hand looks a lot like a right hand
now no matter how I try to shift or
rotate this hand like this I might try
to maybe rotate it 180 degrees so that
the thumb is on the other side like this
image right here but no matter what I do
I will never get be able to make this
thing look like that thing I can shift
it and rotate it it'll just never happen
I will never be able to superimpose the
blue hand on top of this green hand when
I say superimpose literally put it
exactly on top of the green hand so
whenever something is not superimposable
on its mirror image let me write this
down so this is not this is not super
imposable
on its mirror image mirror image we call
it chiral we call it chiral so this hand
drawing right here is an example of a
chiral object or I guess the hand is an
example of a chiral object this is not
superimposable on its mirror image and
it makes sense that is called a chiral
it's called chiral because the word
chiral comes from the Greek the Greek
word for hand Greek Greek for hand and
this definition of not being able to be
superimposable on its mirror image this
applies whether you're dealing with
chemistry or mathematics or I guess just
hands in general so if we extend this
definition to chemistry because that's
what we're talking about there's two
concepts here there are chiral molecules
chiral molecules
and then there are chiral centers or
chiral we'll call them chiral atoms they
tend to be carbon atoms so sometimes
they call them chiral carbons so you
have these chiral and then you have
chiral chiral atoms now chiral molecules
are literally molecules that are not
superimposable on their mirror image so
not I'm not going to write the whole
thing you know not superimposable I'll
just write the whole thing not super
imposable on mirror image mirror image
now for chiral atoms this is essentially
true but when you look for chiral atoms
within a molecule you're the the best
way to kind of spot them is that it's to
recognize that these generally or maybe
I should say usually usually are
carbons especially when we're dealing
with an organic chemistry but they could
be phosphorus or Sulphurs but usually
our carbons our carbons bonded to four
different groups for different four
different groups and I want to emphasize
groups not just for different atoms and
to kind of highlight a molecule that
contains a chiral atom or chiral carbon
we can just think of one so let's say
that I have a carbon right here and I'm
going to set this up so this is actually
a chiral atom that the carbon Pacific is
a chiral atom but it's part of a chiral
molecule and then we'll see examples
that are one or both of these are true
so let's say it's bonded let's say it's
bonded to a let's say it's bonded to a
methyl group from that bond it kind of
pops out of the page let's say it's
there's a bromine over here let's say
behind it there is a hydrogen and then
above it we have a fluorine now if I
were to take the mirror image of this
thing right here we have your carbon in
the center now going to do that same
blue you have the carbon in the center
and then you have the fluorine
love the carbon you have your bromine
now going in this direction you have
this methyl group it's still popping out
of the page but it's now going to the
right instead of to the left so ch3 and
then you have the hydrogen still in the
back these are mirror images if you view
this as kind of the mirror and you can
see on both sides of the mirror now why
is this chiral well no matter and it's a
little bit of a visualization challenge
but no matter how you try to rotate this
thing right here you will never make it
exactly like this thing you might try to
rotate it you might try to rotate it
around like that and try to get the
methyl group over here to get it over
there so let's try to do that but if we
try to get the methyl group over there
what's going to happen to the other to
the other groups well then the hydrogen
group is going or the hydrogen I should
say the hydrogen atom is going to move
there and the bromine is going to move
there but this has the bromine in so
this would be superimposable if this was
a hydrogen and this was a bromine but
it's not though you can imagine that
hydrogen bromine are switched and you
could flip it and do whatever else you
want or try to rotate in any direction
but you're not going to be able to
superimpose them so this molecule right
here is a chiral molecule and this
carbon is a chiral Center so this carbon
is a chiral is a chiral carbon sometimes
called an asymmetric carbon or a chiral
Center it sometimes you'll hear
something called a stereo Center a
serious Center is a more general term
for any point in the a molecule that is
asymmetric relative to the different
groups that is joined to but they all of
these especially you know when you're
kind of an introductory organic
chemistry class tends to be a carbon
bonded to four different groups and I
want to make that I want to stress that
it's not four different atoms you could
have had a methyl group here and a
propyl group here and the carbon would
still be bonded directly to a carbon in
either case but that would still be a
chiral carbon and this would still
actually be a chiral molecule in the
next video we'll do a bunch of a bunch
of examples well we'll look at molecules
try to identify the chiral carbons
then try to figure out whether the
molecule itself is also chiral